question here from magic the dude chef
um
some foods have a decent amount of
protein by the numbers but you know they
have a very low quality protein such as
collagen
when tracking macros how should we
account for this low quality protein
um you know that's a good question um
and collagen is honestly a terrible
protein uh if you're looking at it from
a muscle protein synthesis perspective
uh most
quality scores for it are literally zero
because it has a complete and utter lack
of tryptophan so like if you were just
going to look isolated a dose of
collagen for promoting muscle protein
synthesis
it's a rubbish protein however
within the context of a whole day of
intake and a whole bunch of different
protein sources and in most cases some
very high quality protein sources that
have an abundance of tryptophan um
slipping in a little bit of low quality
protein here and there uh is not
necessarily that bad whether it's a
little bit of collagen here and there uh
some of the lower quality plant-based
proteins so like soy is a very high
quality protein from plant but you know
you start looking down the list at some
of the lower quality ones and you start
to really
think like i don't know this amino acid
profile is pretty weak but
overall i say my general inclination is
to count it as protein and just to make
sure that your total daily protein
intake is adequate you know relative to
your goals and to make sure that you
have a good mixture of proteins in your
diet so
i don't necessarily see a problem with
counting as you know fairly low quality
protein toward your daily total as long
as it's not making up a huge proportion
of your total daily intake um you know
so for example
tying this back into the idea of
vegetarian and vegan diets you know you
can take two low to moderate quality
proteins that have complementary amino
acid profiles put them together and end
up in a really good spot in terms of
muscle protein synthesis so i i don't
like to promote the idea of really
micromanaging amino acid profiles but of
course looking at your diet in its
totality
you want to make sure that you have
enough protein and you want to make sure
that you don't have glaring weaknesses
with regards to any particular essential
amino acids so if you're getting you
know 60 of your daily protein from
collagen that sucks
that's a bad plan but i i don't know if
it makes sense to have this kind of
dueling count going on throughout the
day where you're counting this subtotal
of high quality proteins and this sub uh
subtotal of low quality proteins and
things like that so i'd still count it
toward your your total daily protein but
i would encourage you to try to make
sure that you either have a diet that is
rich in high quality proteins or rich in
proteins that are complementary in
nature when it comes to their amino acid
profile i i can tell you
exactly i mean my
uh experience with with using collagen
protein yeah basically exactly what
you're describing so i um
i started using uh
just like gelatin powder in my meal prep
maybe like two or three months ago um
so one of the things that happens to me
when i'm in a calorie deficit is just
like i get joint aches all the time i
don't know why but like they say ah if
you lose weight your joints will feel
better i gotta i gotta say one of the
reasons why uh
especially when i'm training hard i tend
to want to be in a moderate to sometimes
quite aggressive surplus is that [ __ ]
makes my joints feel good and like you
take calories away and like my hips ache
my knees ache now that i [ __ ] broke
my arm earlier this year my wrist and my
elbow ache those are new um and so uh
i i saw some of the um
the research that's been published on
collagen synthesis with like collagen or
or gelatin supplementation uh and just
thought like you know what it can't it
can't hurt it can't hurt like i'll give
it a shot uh just just throw some
gelatin powder in my meal prep uh i
mostly eat like rice based dishes like
rice and lean protein um
so like yeah i'll just throw some
collagen in make sure it dissolves uh
might help if nothing else uh might
improve the mouth feel like make it
taste a little bit more like luscious
and luxurious
um
and so i just put like 100 grams of
gelatin powder in
like in with the water when the rice is
about to cook
and subjectively one it seems to have
been helping my joints they feel better
don't know if the two are related not an
rct don't necessarily take it as advice
but my personal experience pretty
positive
um
second in terms of just like how i
account for it it's basically what
you're describing so
uh
my most recent meal prep which i did
last night big old batch of congee a lot
of pork um and like 117 grams of
collagen and so the the whole kit and
caboodle has like 740 grams of protein
in total and each serving of it will
probably give me about 55 grams of
protein give or take um
and of that like three quarters of it
probably is from the pork and then
there's enough rice that like a
non-trivial amount of it is from the
rice a little bit from some mushrooms
and then
about a seventh of the total protein in
what i'm consuming comes from the
collagen i added so of those 55 grams of
protein probably like
around 40 or slightly under is is coming
from animal protein and
from there i i figure like ah i'm set
for the meal and then uh maybe some
slightly lower quality
plant proteins um
and then
you know of of the 55 grams probably
eight of them are coming from the
collagen
and like
i don't know it's probably not as
i think i'm consuming enough protein
that having slightly lower like 55 grams
per meal is
more than sufficient
and so if i've replaced those seven
eight grams of of gelatin with more pork
or chicken or whatever i don't know that
i'd really get anything out of it and uh
i mean like you said i just don't want
to micromanage my [ __ ] so
um
with with the addition of that like i
kept my daily protein targets the same
so the amount of quote unquote high
quality protein i'm eating per day has
probably decreased by
12 grams maybe
yeah and like i'm fine with that i
subjectively it doesn't really seem to
be making
a difference in terms of like muscle
retention uh
and then subjectively joints seem to
feel pretty good so i don't know seems
okay
yeah and i think another thing that
contributes to this
because i get this type of question a
lot
something that contributes to it is i
think a lot of people make
dichotomies in their head about protein
sources they're either
a high quality animal based
protein source or a low quality
plant-based protein source and they kind
of just
look at a protein source and say it's
either high quality or low quality
should i count the low quality but
realistically it's a continuous spectrum
and some of your animal sources for
protein are not as high quality as your
other animal sources and there are some
very high quality plant sources and some
very low quality plant sources and so
what i kind of think about in my head is
like you hold up this list of protein
quality scores and say
draw me the line where it doesn't count
anymore uh
very very hard to do that it's our
favorite dichotomizing continuous
variables right but it's best it's very
hard to draw your line
and especially when you consider the
fact that you take a low quality protein
and a low quality protein with
complementary profiles
and all of a sudden you're you're
looking pretty good yeah so yeah going
source by source can be very difficult
but i do
uh encourage people to look at their
diet in its entirety and like greg said
make sure that your collagen is not
you're not doing collagen instead of
chicken right or instead of pork or
whatever whatever the meal was it's uh
collagen
along with you know some of your higher
quality sources the other thing i note
as well is just uh
um
a practice that i've heard from several
people like engaging in recently is just
the idea of
you know when it comes to counting your
your protein for the day kind of
sticking with uh like research based
protein targets like shooting for 1.6
grams per kilo or whatever it is 1.6 1.8
um but then as far as counting your
protein goes only counting the high
quality protein sources so
you know i'm going to make sure that i'm
getting 1.6 1.8 grams per kilo of
protein per day uh but i'm only going to
count like the eggs and chicken and milk
or if you're vegetarian the soy maybe
the mico protein and everything else
just basically not counting it towards
your protein targets for the day
a point that
that i always mention when i see that
is the um
like the protein the research derived
protein recommendations that exist
exist in the context generally of mixed
diets right so
you know if they're saying that like uh
somewhere in the neighborhood of a gram
per pound or like 1.8 grams per kilo
like somewhere in that general vicinity
uh the research saying that like ah
that's probably enough to maximize
hypertrophy or muscle retention in a
deficit and maybe slightly higher for
that but whatever like all of those
targets
are based on studies where people are
eating mixed diets like in those studies
they're not exclusively counting high
quality proteins and so like that's the
context that those
uh that those recommendations
are derived from
and so if you're basing your targets on
1.8 grams per kilo of only high quality
protein there's probably nothing
necessarily bad with that but if you're
doing that because your dietary targets
are being informed by the research your
protein
if you want to make an apples-to-apples
comparison between your diet and the
research that you're basing it on you
are consuming higher protein levels
than
you know is is necessarily being
recommended and that you are using as
your targets and and again i don't think
there's anything wrong with eating
slightly higher levels of protein but
um
if you wanted to go about
counting using that method
you could probably justify slightly
lower protein targets just because some
protein is going to come along for the
ride and virtually everything you eat
so if
that is just the way that you prefer to
count a slightly lower daily protein
target maybe if you're an omnivore like
to 1.4 1.5 grams per kilo would probably
be more justifiable like if you are only
counting the high quality protein you
probably don't need to shoot for quite
1.8 grams per kilo j just because like
that that's not how the research was
done that those uh that those
recommendations were derived from and
just for context i
wish i had the type of memory where i
could give exact numbers but
um
there is a nice paper i saw the other
day that looked at
you know in a typical diet in this
region what percentage of protein comes
from plants and what percent comes from
animal sources it's very likely that
when you look at the studies that were
getting protein recommendations from
like you said the individuals are eating
mixed diets with a mixture of higher and
lower quality protein sources
probably like 40 percent depending on
the region of that protein is coming
from plants that tend to have lower
quality scores so like you said i think
a lot of times we assume oh i need to
make sure i'm getting 1.6 grams per
kilogram of the high quality stuff to
match this literature when in reality
it's very much not matching that
literature